perrin l'anglais messieurs on va voir
maintenant une chanteuse qui fait partie
d'un groupe qui s'appelle moloko si leur
fin de l'hiver un service assez n'était
fermé les yeux
c'est ce qu'on va attendre tout l'hiver
s'émeut locaux et ça s'appelle seen it
bag
c'est une parcelle
maggie
band
c'est tout
cette fille
paris
non
m
payer
voilà le télé je mesure le manga sans
joe johnson johnson john moloko et comme
vous avez pu le remarquer la chanteuse a
les mêmes bases que linda hardy ce qui
veut dire qu'elle aussi est une
maîtresse sado-maso ça fait deux
maîtresses femmes nathalie mabon on va
passer vraiment merci beaucoup merci je
suis sûr que c'est ah oui peut-être
oui je suis sûr et 6 will be done it off
the winter c'est bien volta